we've got a call from kurt in albany new
york hey kurt how's it going
good how you guys going good what's your
question for us
yeah i'm 30 years old i have around 30
000
saved i put 10 000 of that aside as an
emergency fund and i think i'm on baby
step four or going between four and five
i want to get a call from myself that
might be an investment for fifteen
thousand
i wanna get information about if that
you think is a good investment or i
should invest in some other way
i've got a question about your emergency
fund i think anthony's probably going to
ask that too you're 30 years old and
your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses is ten
is ten thousand dollars is that enough
yes yes i think it should be yeah
well you live in new york yeah albany
you live it you must you must live with
your parents
no i pay rent oh you pay rent do you
have roommates
no i'm i live alone or you live alone
okay how much is your rent
my rent i used to pay 1500 now i pay
900. oh
okay all right so three months single
person i can see that 10k is good all
right
all right yeah um uh so that means it'll
leave you over
twenty thousand dollars right uh to
spend towards a car which means
and you said you could find a car for
about 15 grand
yeah i found one that i want which is
actually the 15 is good because usually
i go for 20 000 so i thought maybe it
would be a good investment something i
could enjoy
because i like you know going to the
track and racing and doing that stuff
and
the car isn't going to lose much more
value because it's already a used car
do you already have a vehicle yes okay
so are you trading this vehicle in are
you keeping it
i'm going to keep it that's a i have
like a beater car i just get around it
nah yeah so at your age you don't need
two cars
no no sir yeah yeah i would definitely
if you want to get the car
okay um i would trade in this car
get 5k for the car you're only spending
10k
cash um so that's what i
recommend i mean i mean i'm 36 years old
man i just bought a new car
and i had another one i was thinking
just like you i'm gonna i'm gonna keep
this car
drive this every day as my beater might
get go to work hard and drive my fun car
in the weekend so i was like man that's
just unwise just sell the car
um get some money for it have it go
towards a new car that you want
and so that way you can you know you
don't need two insurance policies you
don't need two gas bills
you don't need two maintenance things so
at your age man you have an option you
can keep the beater car
and stack up some more money and go buy
you something a little bit nicer down
the road and until this one uh
well whenever this one dies off or since
you're already in good position
you're out of debt you got your three
months set aside for emergencies you got
an extra 20k
if you want to go ahead and upgrade your
vehicle now go ahead and do it bro
how much money do you make kurt i make
uh
before taxes i make uh about fifty
thousand a year okay
yeah and the other the other thing to
remember and i think this is good for
different people listening right now
different baby steps or financial
situations
also look at your percentage of income
you don't need two cars
with that type of income that's a fine
income you can continue to increase it
you know in in the future
but you know if someone was at calling
in and they're a millionaire and they
want to buy another car yeah okay buy
another car yeah
it's a small percentage of the overall
picture so we just don't want you to be
strained financially where a large
percentage
of your income is going to something
that's unnecessary like
two vehicles you don't need two vehicles
you can have the the new car like
anthony said but just sell the other one
and that percentage christy it's 50
you don't want your cars to be worth
more than 50
um of your take-home pay bottom line
okay and so i will go ahead and trade
that car in man
and then just boom um drive nicer i mean
just go ahead and trade in and just
drive nicer man but you you've done
great kurt yeah
um i'm proud of you bro uh i just don't
don't don't pay for two car insurance
not right now you don't need that
expense over your head